(Italian music)
- Hey, Bridget. Whatcha doing?
- Oh, I'm just getting ready
for the super fun new year's
party we're having tonight.
Yeah.
- When did we agree to New Year's party?
- I don't know.
Oh my God.
- Oh, since we're all here.
We should have a New Year's party.
- New year's party suck.
- Yeah, I hate new year's.
- We could have those
glasses that say 2017.
- Yes, oh my God.
Let's do it.
- I love new year's.
- Ahhhh.
- The wine has betrayed us.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Ugh, this sucks.
- I know. I hate having
to find someone to kiss.
Like why is it important
that I start my new year's
by putting my lips on a stranger's lips?
- I hadn't even thought of that part.
Fuck.
I don't want to spend another
30 years worrying about that.
I wish I could just be like--
- One, happy new year.
(horns blare, group cheers)
(slow jam music)
- Yeah or it could be like--
- Make a wish.
- It already came true.
You know I watched a lot of
eighties movies last week.
- Okay, but our goal is clear.
- Right.
- We look super hot and find
someone to kiss at midnight.
- We watch "16 Candles" and cry.
Your plan is better, yeah,
let's do that. (sighs)
(upbeat electronic music)
♫ I'm trying to party all
night cuz I'm feeling it
- Hey, what do you think of this?
- [Maddie] Oh, I like it.
Are you gonna wear tights?
- Um, let me see if I have any.
- You know I'm gonna be optimistic
and say that we're gonna
have a lot of fun tonight.
- Yeah, as long as I don't
have to watch Jack and Bridget
make out for the 100th time.
- Sigh, dude you have to
tell her how you feel.
- Or I could just suffer quietly
like the masochist that I am.
- [Maddie] I really do hate
seeing you like this though.
Do you think this is too slutty?
- You look the perfect amount of slutty.
- Oh good. That's what I'm going for,
just a little bit of slutty.
- Oh, but have you talked to Bridget
about how weird it is
that she's seeing your ex.
- (Sighs) Ugh, I wanted
to, but then I got busy
and I saw Jack with this other girl
and I just went into full avoidance mode.
- Wait, you know we as a group
are not great at communication.
- (Chuckles)
- Guys, can you see my
underwear through this?
- Uh, nope, no, no, no, no,
no, oh here look at this.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Oh wow.
- Whoa, new year's.
- Hey guys.
- Hi, hi.
- Yeah, alright.
- I'll get us some more drinks.
- Yeah, thank you.
Excuse me, ladies.
(Laughter)
- They're really funny.
- So funny.
♫ Pop it on the floor and
then you bring it right back
♫ Pop, pop it on the floor and
♫ Go on, pop it on the floor
♫ Because I love it
when you move that there
♫ Show em where they do that at
- Hey, Jack.
- Hey, Maddie.
This is Jamie.
- Hi.
- [Jamie] Hi.
- Are you gonna tell Bridget?
- Uh, yeah tell her when?
- About that.
(camera snaps photo)
- [Jack] Um.
- Bye, Jamie.
- Are you stalking me?
- No, I'm not stalking you.
Don't flatter yourself.
- Okay, look Bridget
and I aren't exclusive.
- Does she know that?
- Well we never had the talk
so I think it's pretty clear.
- (Chuckles) Oh, okay.
Just tell her okay or I will.
(upbeat electronic music)
(bell pings)
- Yeah, so Bridget's great.
- Oh my God, I know.
- Oh my God, Randall, you're so funny.
- But, I didn't say anything.
- There it is again.
(bell pings)
- Uh yeah, so where--
- Oh my God, she did the
cutest thing this one time,
I have to tell you this.
(bell pings)
[Elliot's Mom] Put your party hat on.
- I will mom.
[Elliot's Mom] Now, please.
(phone rings)
- Hey, Mad.
- Hi, no one will hook up with me.
- Wait, what's happening?
- We're having a party
and it's the worst thing.
I tried to hook up with this guy
and he didn't want to and I miss you.
- Why wouldn't this guy hook up with you?
Is he a crazy person?
- I know, right?
I mean I look good tonight.
- Dude, new year's always sucks.
You can put so much stake
into a single night.
- Yeah, you're right.
I mean I'm here watching the
ball drop with my parents.
So, you're already having
a better night than me.
- That's adorable.
- Yeah, it's so cute when they
fall asleep before midnight
and I'm alone scrolling
through people's Instagrams
seeing their cool parties.
(June knocks on door)
[June] Madison.
- I gotta go.
- Me too.
- Take a shot for me.
- Way ahead of ya.
(phone hangs up)
[Elliot's Mom] Elliot, come say goodbye
to your grandparents.
- Uhhhh.
- Hey.
- Bridget and Jack are making
out can we please do shots?
- Yes.
- You know what?
I think I'm actually just
gonna call it a night.
I don't--
- June, you have to say something.
- I know.
- (Laughs) Why are you
guys in the bedroom?
(cups drop)
- Oh, oops. (giggles)
- I'll go grab paper towels.
Oh my God. Jack says I'm built like a bull
(slurs) when I'm drunk.
(laughs) He's such an ass.
I love him.
- I what?
- Kind of just fell out of my mouth.
But, I think I am in love with Jack.
[Bridget] Oh Madison, I'm sorry.
- June--
God dammit, Bridget.
Don't go, okay.
- I can't do this right--
- Why are you doing this?
- Look I was supposed to talk
to you about me and Jack,
I just don't know what to say.
I'm sorry.
- It's not about Jack, okay.
- It's about June and me.
- You're making her miserable.
- What?
[Male Guest] Hey everyone,
the ball's about to drop.
- [June] No, you're not
making me miserable.
(Group counting down)
- How do you not see that
she's in love with you?
And you just parade Jack around the house
like there's no effect?
- June is that true?
- Madison said Jack is cheating on you.
- What?
(group cheers)
(Auld Lang Syne song)